when you understand that every single
cell
can has the capacity to connect to
the original source of life
you will become a gravitational force
that you cannot imagine the power of you
will draw to yourself everything that
you could possibly dream of to manifest
a reality that you don't think you're
worthy of yet you will be a
gravitational force that will bring in
so much goodness to you
so much capacity for rebirth
so much capacity for forgiveness for
yourself that you can start to live in
the resonance of gratitude for the fact
that you are animated in the human body
right now the tipping point not of a
planet not of a species of the tipping
point of a universe that wants to
resonate at a better harmony we are
about to uplevel the orchestra in this
universe and all of the entities are
paying attention because our planet is
uniquely positioned in the galactic
geometry of this universe we actually
are at a chakra point uh we are a chakra
center within this universe and if we
shift this one chakra the whole system
shifts
and we
can change it for everything everything
in the universe will shift if we will
align the gravitational force of one
human being coming into perfect
coherent alignment with the the four
energies this masculine and feminine
are the words that we've put on these
energies but basically the masculine is
is an energetics of linear force and and
form and the feminine is the information
that streams through that
that geometry
and so within you is a rigid geometry
linear geometry that is
flexible in that it can change the
direction of flow through it but its
components are actually quite rigid and
so it's a beautiful reality that we're
in in that
when we start to think about masculine
and feminine we need to let go of the
biologic you know baggage on those two
words man woman you know husband man
it's not about that it's literally
structural
and so as we start to bring this
together
those 70 trillion
pulling those energies together of the
masculine form and the feminine flow
his form and flow come together within
that individual the coherence within the
single cell prevents the capacity for
any dis-ease because it is emanating
with such true coherence to self
and ultimately that is what healing is
healing happens when you reach a
coherent state of self
and that's what i want for everybody who
would come through something that i
would build and
i had to shut a clinic
to allow that to happen because the
clinic
was a model that demonstrated that they
didn't they weren't enough every person
in there wasn't enough to heal so they
needed me they needed a whole medical
system they needed a whole thing
[ __ ] that we are so much bigger than
that we are so much bigger than that we
are so ready to blow the doors off this
thing
if you can't feel it in your body yet
then i just urge you to go sit in front
of the ocean and just
sit at the base of a mountain and just
freaking listen and then feel into your
own body feel what it feels like to
resonate and you're going to have to go
through all the emotional
overlay that's going to happen because
then when you start to resonate it's
going to shake up all of the all of the
trauma all of the doubts and
insecurities
and i just went through this in the last
12 hours again of just like being faced
with my own
human frailty
failure of expression
brokenness of like really that's that's
how i'm expressing myself really that's
how oh my god and then we have a
tendency to retract
and we're resonating higher so we're
exposing new things and everything wants
us to retract and be afraid of our own
power
and the message that came through this
morning is so clear is go bigger go
bigger
go bigger than that because we can get
there go bigger than the fear of hurting
each other go bigger because it's okay
to hurt each other if it's out of an
effort to get to our own resonant state
of truth
we will have enough grace and
forgiveness for each other to work
through the relational challenges that
come
you are going to create a lot of
disruption in your life if you do any of
the things we've been talking about for
the last hour it is going to be
extremely disruptive and so that's my
disclaimer on all of this
you are treading on holy ground when you
step into these spaces and if you start
to go down this path it will be
extremely destructive to your current
way of life
and thank god for that thank god that
you have the possibility of blowing up
the matrix you can just
push
all of you can push right now
and i don't think it's going to take
more than two of us
to change everything
it really just come into perfect
harmonic alignment with those mastin and
feminine the course of miracle says if
one pair
will come into complete coherence it
will change the consciousness of the
whole planet
and scriptures all over the place say
this where two or more are gathered i am
where two or more are gathered i am
i am
the most beautiful thing you will ever
see can you get to that point where you
can
sit there and close your eyes and say i
am
the most beautiful thing the universe
will ever see it's going to take some
ceremony it's going to take some
dismantling
belief systems
have you been able to say that
i said it for the first time
at the end of january this year and
it was really hard fought to get there i
had to dismantle a lot in my life to get
there and
the human mind
is so conditioned into a split state
with the ego
shield that
it's
not a one-step
event uh it creates you have to create a
lifestyle that allows for the the
possibility of being able to say that
in a continuous soundtrack of your life
rather than
a one-time connection to that reality
the one-time connection
happens in a million different ways and
uh for humanity
but a world that perpetuates that day in
and day out has not been seen yet
and so that's our challenge
to all of us
but the exciting thing is you don't have
to imagine what that would look like it
will simply be manifest out of
the space between everything we've
created that new reality is going to
emerge
and in just recent weeks i have this
deep feeling that we have it's already
finished that already happened
and now our neurosensory complex that we
call human consciousness is catching up
to see it
but i believe it has happened
i believe that on this
continuum of life and light beings
we completed something
in the recent weeks that's extremely
important
and we've done it in the midst of school
shootings we've done it in the midst of
new efforts toward war we've done it in
the midst of one of the worst famines in
in history in africa we've done in the
midst of
cataclysmic damage to the planet uh that
we continue to met out
and so
that's the grace of the universe is
the harmonics of light beings
cannot be dismayed
by the behavior of a little bit of
biology how are we the same as the
planet because when we know how to take
care of ourself we take care of the
planet we know how to take care of the
planet we can maybe know how to take
care of ourselves so one of the biggest
aches i feel in myself is
that most humans are walking around not
knowing or not being able to hear how
much they are left
and it sends such deep ache into my body
when i come present with that
knowingness
there are 7.9 billion people walking
around in an incomplete knowledge of
and perhaps not even the inkling of
experience of how much they are loved
and love is um not a thing
love is an experience that happens when
you see beauty
and when you see the beauty and nature
around you you are experiencing love at
its purest form
love is a frequency of resonance that
occurs when
your
being witnesses the beauty of another
being
and the most exquisite being that we all
share is this planet
and so our connection to the divine is
the nation we live within
and
if you will go out to watch a sunset
wherever you are
i promise it's the same sunset i'm
watching tonight wherever i am
we are sharing the beauty of this planet
all the time if we will stop and listen
and the reason i feel such egg is not
just because we are walking around not
loving each other because we can't see
the beauty in ourselves therefore we
cannot see the beauty in the other human
next to us
i take on a much bigger level for some
reason i i can feel this thing
that is so big
for some reason
it's so much bigger than the human drama
of a lack of
sense of beauty and lack of love for one
another
is the fact that the earth itself
nature itself sees our beauty
sees our beauty
and loves
towards us
and we are deflecting that
you think it's sad not to love your
partner or spouse or child at the pure
state of beingness
it is much sadder that you cannot
receive from an entire universe that
sees you and is sending back to you an
awe-inspired joy that you are here right
now
that you are here right now
what a what a tragedy
this is definitely juliet
killing herself thinking that her lover
is dead
when her lover has concocted the perfect
plan to stay asleep long enough
that there could be freedom to love
we are in our romeo and juliet moment
with the universe
are we going to kill ourselves in our in
our sense of hopelessness
because we thought that we what we saw
was real
or are we going to realize there's a
deeper reality that love cannot be
conquered and therefore it is not dead
and therefore we should stay alive long
enough to feel it
and if she had just waited a few more
minutes
if she had just waited a few more
minutes we wouldn't have that story to
tell
and so i invite all of us
to stay alive a few more minutes
together let's encourage each other to
stay alive a few more minutes
and wait for this story to get to us
that has already completed itself which
we are loved we are seen we are home and
this is our home and we will make it
home when we resonate together when we
harmonize we will find the symphony of
the new humanity
and we will express something much
different than we have before
[Music]